لليوم السادس على التوالي تتواصلوا اعمال
اخماد الحريق في ميناء اسكندرون التابع
لمحافظتها تاي والواقع شرقي البحر المتوسط
تعرض هذا الميناء لاضرار هيكليه شديده
بسبب الزلزال الذي وقع فجر يوم الاثنين
الماضي نشاهد في الصوره كثير من سيارات
الاطفاء ورجال الاطفاء الذين يسعون لاخماد
هذا الحريق وضمان اخماده سواء كان ذلك من
البر او عبر بخ المياه من البحر طبعا
عشرات ان لم يكن مئات الحاويات انهارت
الكتل التي جمعت بها جراء الزلزال الذي
وقع بدايه الاسبوع
الذي انتهى وهذا الذي ترونه هنا هو واحد
من الاضرار التي تسبب بها الزلزال لكم ان
تتخيلوا حجم الضرر الاقتصادي في هذا
المكان يتم تجميع رماد هذه الحاويات وما
بقي منها في اماكن منفصله وهنا محاولات
لابعاد ما يمكن مما لم يحترق من هذه
الحاويات حتى لا ينتشر الحريق بشكل اكبر
طبعا تغيير وجهه هذه الحاويات الى موانئ
جديده في تركيا هو حاله قد تكون مطروحه
وذلك لاستمرار عمليه الشحن البحري هنا
ربما اكثر من 1500 حاويه في هذا المكان
وطبعا السؤال الابرز هو الان متى يمكن
لهذا الميناء التجاري الهام ان يعود للعمل
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره هاتاي من ميناء
اسكندرون